let's look at this first line and what
it's gonna do for us it's going to
create an object that delegates to car
dot prototype which is what we're
already doing that means we can get rid
of the part where we were doing that
ourselves it also seems to be assigning
the result of that object creation to
the keyword this now even though you
couldn't possibly write this line of
code in your own programs the
interpreter is capable of finding values
to the keyword this it kind of makes
sense and is in keeping with our
understanding of what the keyword this
is used for the intention of the keyword
this is to be a convenient way of
referring to whatever the target object
is in some object-oriented function call
this function call is pretty object
oriented the intent is that we're going
to build a new thing so it makes a lot
of sense that whatever that new thing is
could be the target of the keyword this
now that we have a way of referring to a
brand new object that's created to
delegate to the car prototype we might
as well get rid of all of these new
table that we introduced we can just
instead use the keyword this lastly we
can tell that this return statement that
will be inserted by the interpreter
seems to duplicate what's being done
above in the line that we wrote it's
unnecessary to have to return statements
and in fact the way this code would
operate we should never be able to reach
the last line since the second-to-last
line would already have returned from
the function we can get rid of the
return statement that we wrote as well
and just trust that this inserted return
statement will do the work we need we're
done refactoring to avoid the
duplication between the code we had
written and the code that got inserted
for us but remember this code is just a
mental note to remind us what the
keyword new does so let's get rid of
those notes because we know they're not
actually going to show up anywhere in
our program let's take away the extra
whitespace so that we can see it written
more clearly this is what we would
expect to type when we're making a
pseudo-classical class